I'm Josh wolf and I'm about to answer
the internet check out my YouTube page
for all my stand-up would you rather
walk in on your dad having sex with a
dog or a dog having sex with your dad
this is an easy answer my dad having sex
with a dog hey nobody [ __ ] my dad you
know I'm saying that's [ __ ] up how
dare you I would rather see him I mean
it's gotta be a full breed I don't want
him [ __ ] a mutt I don't want him
dragging our family name through the mud
but as long as it's a full breed like in
a respectable breed like a Rottweiler or
Doberman someone looked like he really
had to wrestle with I'm on board for
that so my dad [ __ ] a dog easy come
loudly every time you fart or fart
loudly every time you come easy one
again more coming the better you know
what I mean I think I would actually add
prunes to my diet
because are you telling me I come every
time I fart is that a problem like that
seems like something I would pay for can
I go to the doctor and get that do they
attach that like I think I would go fart
[ __ ] is actually also funny like if
you're like ah like I would be pretty
great I would actually try to make a
cooler [ __ ] noise but I say definitely I
definitely say [ __ ] loudly every time I
fart and I would fart make it a point to
fart a lot on the plane would you rather
be an extremely good-looking paralyzed
person or a hideous looking person who
can walk I am gonna go with walk and I'm
gonna tell you why because I can change
this you know what I mean
surgery or you know what I can also be I
can be that hideous looking dude with a
chiseled diesel body
I still got diesel body because you know
those if you put on the opposite there
are some women that you've seen whose
faces he but their bodies and they're
still getting it but the paralyzed guy I
mean you can't even look at yourself in
the mirror so what good is it to be
good-looking you know what I mean what
do you guys say bring the mirror over
here that doesn't sound like a lot of
fun it's it doesn't matter how good
looking you are
if somebody's wiping your ass so that's
what I would say would you hook up with
someone with a colostomy bag well I have
to
do I have the colostomy bag or today
they have the costumey bag yeah that'd
be a good story I think it'd be a great
story you know what I mean I think I
would even hold it up like this
yeah like show it like it was an IV bag
I think but I think so I think so and I
bet you it's kind of warm so it might
feel good but I would go colostomy bag
yeah I would why not
would you rather kill 25 kittens in a
row or one dog 25 kittens in a row
that's not even close are you a cat
here's all you need to know a cat if you
die a cat will eat you they within a day
they say a cat will eat you they don't
give a [ __ ] the only reason look the
only reason the cat doesn't kill you is
because it's not big enough you know
what the big cats do they kill you they
kill you
the only reason your cat doesn't kill
you is because it knows it can't [ __ ] a
cat I go with the I would rather kill 25
kittens in a row do I get to choose how
I kill him you know how you ever seen
whack-a-mole boink boink boink boink
maybe a couple of miniature golf clubs I
don't know I'd be creative if specially
I wouldn't kill this dog if this is the
one that's [ __ ] my dad because I want
to make sure he has a healthy dog would
you rather be Magic Johnson or just your
regular self without a it's Magic
Johnson not even close
are you kidding me Magic Johnson is a
national hero he's got the good aids to
the one that makes you bigger and
stronger I don't know how he got that
aids but I want someone like that it
seems like he seems healthier now than
he did when he was playing professional
basketball so yeah I'd rather be Magic
Johnson rich I didn't lose my wife or my
family I got more popular yeah I'm going
Magic Johnson without a doubt would you
rather have two average kids or one kid
go on to be a pro athlete and one kid
can't read I'd go with one kid pro
athlete and what kid can't read a
hundred percent because I'm gonna just
I'm gonna make the one kid who can't
read follow the per athlete around and
carry his bag or some [ __ ]
but I want a pro athlete I want the
tickets I want the perks and I'm gonna
ask that pro athlete to take care of the
dumb mom would you rather burp the sound
of a gong or sneeze the sound of
bowling strike what's the sound oh well
I say sneeze the sound of a bowling
strike because how would that work and
not only that like that would really
like because I on planes I always as I
fly a lot if I'm two rows back and I
hear the sound of a bowling strike I'm
getting nervous I'm like what the [ __ ]
so if I if I could make someone scare it
every time I sneezed I think I would go
bowling strike would you [ __ ] the
ugliest teacher you ever had yes oh is
that not the question
Oh a would you [ __ ] the obvious teacher
ever had to [ __ ] the hottest teacher you
ever had yeah listen
most guys would [ __ ] the ugly teacher
they ever had just for the story then
that's a hard no that's a that's a hard
pass there was a dude there was a
teacher that I had whose body odor was
so bad but he also used to stand and yet
Chester he had his shirt button to hear
and he would talk to you and he would
twirl the chest hair and slowly rip it
out of his chest and sprinkle it on the
ground in front of him and his bow he
smelled that dude smelled so bad and he
always had food in his beard there was
one time he had a piece of cheese in his
[ __ ] eyebrow and I was just staring
at him like what am I doing here yeah so
I would say no do you think you could
beat any creature on earth armed with
two samurai swords no no yeah I'm gonna
tell you right now so me versus a bear
go grizzly bear I'm gonna tell you how
that goes right now first I should then
I run I don't care what I have in my
hands [ __ ] and then run and so I think
he catches me Samurai probably fall on
the samurai sword and kill myself before
I'm probably and then that's the end of
that but no I'm listen guys I don't know
if you can tell by my incredible
physique and personality but I'm not a
big fighter I'm not really I'm not real
good at that
yeah it doesn't yeah you're not
automatically Jetley you're still the
[ __ ] who can't open the pickle jar
you know what I mean so I'm not sure
sex sports are really gonna help you out
with that if you count to a million
you get one million dollars you cannot
take breaks you cannot mess up could you
do it guys I'm so high all the time no
no no no no no there's zero chance I
forget what I'm talking about
most mid-sentence so there's no way I
could count to a million now if you had
no I could yeah yeah I know I definitely
could not no I couldn't do that would
you rather be in a country music video
or a rap music video for the rest of
your life country music video all day
every day
you know they look like they're having a
good time
country music right now is like 80's
rock that you go to the con there having
a good time the women are hot people are
drinking beers we're hanging out in a
truck I don't know why we're all
swimming in an above-ground pool but
whatever we're doing it and we're having
a good time doing it
so I definitely go country music video
and here's the problem with me doing and
being a rap music video I'm a terrible
dancer so honestly that you want to see
me run did my running man okay okay yeah
but I could do the I could do that but I
could but I couldn't do that okay so I
think this is the yeah isn't this the
running man is yeah I can't shuffle I
can't yeah I want to say one thing to
white guys look here's the deal
don't dance with both half of your body
pick a hat pick the upper half because
you can kind of stay right here you're
in B it's the lower half people where
you look we only will be your lower half
no no no pick the upper half stick with
it don't move your lower half and make
eye contact if you were in Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory how would you get
kicked out I'll tell you how because I'd
be super [ __ ] high and I would just
start eating everything and if he told
me hey you can't eat that I would be
eat dicks I'm high as [ __ ] that's more
than chocolate yeah I would get kicked
out I would also get kicked out because
I would probably put some of the weed
chocolate into the regular chocolate I
like surprising people with getting high
because sometimes I'm gonna be I'm
feeling a little lightheaded I'm like
dad it's like a game show you're high
yeah it's but I would do that well you
don't to see really Wonka high you think
that dudes not smoking weed Willy Wonka
come on if you can make one movie
character real to date you who would it
be
Jessica Rabbit come on that Jessica
Rabbit without a doubt because I also
feel like cartoon characters are bendy
you know I mean so I feel like you can
really do a lot of weird stuff that you
couldn't do with regular people Jessica
Rabbit for sure no there's zero chance
listen you're not [ __ ] cartoons and
be bad in bed do you know what I mean
cuz they can go they can turn their dick
into hammers you know what I mean so you
if you for sure if you're [ __ ] a
cartoon character you do you know what's
going on would you rather have to tell
your mom everything you've ever done
sexually or have to show her your porn
history woo
I would rather tell her everything I've
done sexually because I like making
people uncomfortable so I would make
sure we sat down at the table and I
would make sure I maintained eye contact
and I would take her step-by-step porn
history is gonna make her really worried
for me as a human being do you know what
I mean like just like google search can
I tell you my son's friend was at the
house and they were using my computer
and they hit the google search and I
clear when I think I've done like weird
sex stuff but I hear Jacob go dad
why were you googling zebra diarrhea
yeah oh my god don't worry about it
buddy you know what I mean yeah it's
just yeah I'm so sorry but yeah I would
rather want her to see the porn history
because a lot of the poor in history
isn't stuff I'm jerking off to it's more
stuff like I wonder if they've ever made
that do you know what I mean that's more
like what it is
yeah like I googled [ __ ] porn it's
the worst thing I've ever googled I'm
just I'm not well I'm so sorry I did
that it's the only thing I've ever
regret regretted googling it was the
only thing I've the the sounds were
really tough we I mean I'm I'm a sick
person but that even that I was like oh
boy like I've hit my threshold of where
twice but once was just because I was
like oh it's here
yeah so but yeah I know that was a rough
one for me
would you rather fart popcorn or sneeze
butter fart popcorn guys again farts are
funny is it an actual popcorn um farting
or the smell does it have butter on it
because it seems like it might be a
little touchy coming out yes no butter
dry popcorn I get a sneeze butter then
yeah it's already a mess
but I I don't want to dry popcorn it
feels like eventually is gonna be a lot
of chafing and honestly say you fart and
like it's a couple of popcorns and now
you've got a little a little load and
you're I don't want and what are gonna
say no it's just popcorn it's not poop
it's just about people going whatever no
no it's just
is that better popcorn yeah no not
better sneeze butter sneeze buddy would
you rather have sex with a girl with no
arms that's the whole question oh I
added rather in there yes what I have I
will tell you there was a girl in
college who had one arm and there may
have been she had a great sense of humor
and so maybe one of my friends used to
call her slot and and he would walk up
to her at a bar and he would
he would when they cuz she liked it she
would put her arm up her little arm like
this and he would pull it and he would
put his hand out by her [ __ ] be like no
lemons no lemons but when I have sex
with a girl with no arms yeah why not
what's what's the problem is there a
problem like they no arms but a vagina
right ok so as long as the vagina still
there I think we're good to go you
telling me you wouldn't want to see two
nubs Jaguars like this Oh
dolphin Anja come on with two flippers
that would be amazing
hi there's gotta be now that's gonna add
to my google porn search because now I'm
going to google it I'm gonna google it
like this come on somebody's made that
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
masturbated to well I know what I'm
gonna masturbate to later and that's the
[ __ ] flippers I I honestly don't know
how to answer this the weirdest thing
I've ever masturbated to I do you know
how to answer that do you know what the
weirdest thing you've ever masturbated
okay that's where that's where I'll
watch just about anything because I like
I have some things on my phone man okay
I have seen a video this dude with two
hands I'll show you the video it's on my
phone oh my god try to just should I
describe it to your show it to you okay
he a guy first you don't you don't know
what it is it's just like these guys
hands his hands are just they're gone
and he's doing this and then you realize
oh hey both of his hands are in
somebody's butt and then out he pulls
this giant purple
honeycomb looking prolapsed but it's
giant it looks like a huge beehive
and it's purple and then he does this he
does this and he starts to suck it and I
have to tell you I came so fast no I
have to tell you that was the weirdest
it's so I've shown
well here's thick III videotape people
watching that because the reaction
without them knowing what it is is so
amazing I like weird [ __ ] everybody I
love Richard that's why I love these
questions I love weird stuff I love
answering weird stuff it makes me happy
yeah